hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we are in our
final round of our coverage of the 2017
US Chess Championships we have a
three-way tie going into the final round
with Wesley so vada Cobian and Alex oh
no shucks and none of them play each
other so they not only have to do well
but they have to hope that the other two
don't do well in their games all three
of them are going to be playing the
black pieces so it is going to be very
difficult the biggest thing they need to
make sure they do is do not lose put a
lot of pressure on your opponent's if
you can get a draw that would not be the
worst result but in today's match we
have one of those competitors Wesley so
that's tied at the top he's playing the
black and then White's going to be
played by Daniel NAT eats game he needs
a full point to lock up invitation to
the World Cup so he has a lot to play
for so we'll go and get started with
Daniel starts with Pawnee for Pawnee
five nine f3 in the knight to c6 getting
into the right Lopez with Bishop to b5
and as we have seen throughout many many
recent tournaments we see Knight to f6
getting into the Berlin defense and then
castle on the Kings side pretty standard
Knight takes d4 pawn up to d4 all the
same moves we have seen lately
and then after Knight to d6 we see kind
of the first change in various receive
pawn takes on e5 pretty much all the
games we've seen for a while now our
Bishop takes here on c6 and then you
know the pawns going to recapture for
once your could always recapture with
this B pawn as well but decides to go
ahead and take with this pawn here on e5
and then that forces Knight takes on b5
and then pawn up to 84 this nights going
to fall there's no safe Square for him
to go to it kind of comes down to where
he wants that to go he could said you
know I'm just going to allow you to take
that back here I'm going to continue to
develop my board state somewhere else
could play pawn here to d6 but decided
to go ahead and move his nice Knight
down here to d4 Knight takes see a lot
of exchanges on board Queen down here to
d4 and then pawn to d5 and and for
here Daniel decides to play a move on
Posada if you're not too familiar with
it is once your opponent plays their
pawn up twice and you are you know for
white specifically if you are level with
them so you'd be on the fifth rank if
you're white you have one movement one
that move only to take like this so
that's what he does he takes here on d6
capturing the pawn here on d5 if you're
not familiar with it it is a legal move
although it may look somewhat odd if
you're not very familiar with move Queen
down here to d6 and here's where things
got somewhat interesting I would see
Queen to e4 and Wesley so I think has
two options he could play Queen to e6 he
could also play Bishop to e7 getting
ready to castle on the kingside
completed a development he does have the
double Bishop here so he had that going
for him decides to go for the Queen to
e6 route and then both players do
threefold repetition and we have a draw
after 14 moves which is which is really
really odd Wesley so afterwards was
interviewed and they were kind of asking
like hey why did you not go for the win
you have a lot to play for and he said
he was ready for a long game he wasn't
necessarily expecting this variation in
the Berlin defense and he wasn't the one
he felt forced the draw he thought that
Daniel was the one that forced it but I
do think Wesley so had the opportunity
to play that Bishop here at the e7 and
not have a four astrology I mean even
after the first one Queen here to e4 you
could see Bishop e7 and then Bishop f4
getting involved into the game Queen e6
yes they want to exchange off the board
that's not going to be too terrible you
still have those double Bishop pair if
he doesn't want to exchange maybe nice
to see three protecting you could take
the Queen's off the board you still have
that double bishop pair Bishop down here
to f5 you could cast on the King side
cast on the Queen side if it's not going
to be an easy in game but it gives you
some opportunities instead of a
threefold repetition after 14 moves
that's sort of lame I think
luckily for Wesley so his other two
people did not win their game vada
Cobian actually ended up losing to
Nakamura and then Alex oh no shucks he
did draw as well so we will have a
playoff so for those
people that like extra chess we will
have a playoff going into tomorrow with
Wesley so and Alex Thomas Chuck but all
round 11 across the board was not the
fireworks that maybe I was expecting
just because we've seen fireworks this
entire series some people were saying
that you know Daniel he's a student at
Stanford maybe at school tomorrow I'm
not sure how much truth there is to that
but all in all I don't think either side
really wanted to play too long today
because we had to have a threefold
repetition draw after 14 moves so thanks
for watching the very very quick video
and I will see you guys in coverage of
the tie breakers Thanks
have a good one